and get ready for Anarchy in Atlanta
violent antifa thugs are calling for a
night of rage against law enforcement
tomorrow after police shot and killed a
man because he started shooting at a
State Trooper without warning police say
it was in self-defense cops were raiding
an autonomous Zone that was set up to
protest a proposed Law Enforcement
Training Center the sickening call for
violence was posted on Twitter but taken
down it called for quote reciprocal
violence to be done to the police and
their allies
but Georgia cops aren't backing down to
the threats
acts such as arson physical attacks on
members of our community
Focus intimidation of citizens the use
of explosives and setting booby traps
that have the potential of causing great
bodily harm
or could possibly maim
are not acts of peaceful protests they
are criminal acts that destabilize
communities and endangered citizens do
you think this is getting a lot of media
coverage Craig Gutfeld I was just
thinking you know how all we hear about
from the Democrats and the media is this
invisible world of white supremacy and
yet antifa is just out there doing
whatever they want and if you look at
them they're overwhelmingly white
they're Misfits they're miserable and
initially the media had elevated them
because they actually agreed with them
because they had they were anti-fascists
remember CNN I wonder I you know and you
know
if anybody else had been saying this
would be viewed as hate speech it'd be
seen as a threat to democracy but I
think that the way the media still looks
at this stuff they've learned nothing
from George Floyd that this is not the
voice of the oppressed these are people
who want to destroy Society right so I
think that like this is you would like
to see this treated differently the cops
get more support the media back off and
say you know what let's not bet on the
wrong horse this time that costs
billions of dollars in damage cost
dozens of lives in the riots and then
thousands of lives with a with a crime
epidemic maybe we should sit this one
out and support the cops it's a pretty
big statement to to call for Mass
violence against law enforcement and
their allies which is pretty much
everybody so anarchists have been
camping out in this park in Atlanta for
a long time they have one of these
autonomous zones and they're protesting
the building of a police training
facility
because training police is bad they want
less time apparently and also the
arrested antifa terrorists 22 years old
son of a millionaire from Maine lived in
a big house sailed on the yacht and now
he gets to live in the woods look they
allowed these nuts to live in the woods
for way too long and think about what is
happening all across the country with
homelessness problems let this be a
warning don't allow these nuts to live
out in the woods like this
do something about it that the homeless
problems everywhere these people are
this this is a choice this guy is a rich
kid I want them to live in the woods
away from me yeah well okay well they're
not getting eaten by bears they're not
just living in the woods camping they're
building tree houses and throwing
Molotov cocktails of people judge you
know I thought this was over after the
summer of 2020. these Chas and these
autonomous zones and I kind of read this
today and I said oh my gosh it's back so
now we've got people who really believe
that a night of rage is appropriate
self-defense reciprocal violence you
know that's Anarchy that is total
Anarchy we either believe in Law and
Order or we don't and by the way don't
you need a permit of some type you know
to go into these places if I want to
camp out in the woods or you have an RV
or you want to go camp out you've got to
have some kind of a uh some permit okay
or else it's trespass get them the hell
out of there and let them know who's
running the place why hasn't Joe Biden
condemned the treehouse antifa
that's an excellent question Joe Biden
has a lot on his plate
it's mostly gelatin
unkind and I don't think that much
gelatin Joe Biden has been very clear
about violence he's actually condemned
antifa which is just like an unorganized
mass of people who hate fascism and
white supremacies
well no I think that what he said which
was mirroring what uh Christopher Ray
said they had the FBI that it is this
loose organization of people and people
like to make it out as if this is super
centralized but it's not actually what
it is are people in disparate locations
from Atlanta to Seattle
so it's like the proud boys
what no the proud boys is quite
organized oh there you go isn't it I
don't know I'm just asking you what no I
don't even get how that's a trick that
you made me stumble into I think
um
all violence is bad and what's talking
to me about the story is obviously the
horror of this police officer being shot
but the disconnect between what's going
on on the Advent the quote advocacy
front and how people feel about it on
the ground the police are popular
they're especially popular in places
with high minority populations that want
there to be more cops on the street
versus less cops on the street and you
are right
if you're trespassing that should be the
charge I think it's in Louisville right
where they if someone has a tent out
they just arrest you and they just take
you in right away and I think that
they're going to have to start doing
that in other places good all right I
didn't Joe Budden bailout antifa what in
the summer of 2020.
said that you could donate to the
Minnesota bail fund who do you think
they were going to protect not antique
people why are you defending the proud
boys
do not do that I went on Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now